alright it is now a full-blown psychosis
it is a psychological well a level of
unhinge Minh I've never seen Trump
derangement syndrome out of control
remember if your dog bites at the bee
stings if the baby cries and you're
feeling sad it's all president Trump's
fault if he literally cures cancer they
will never give him credit in the media
now according to the Editorial Board of
the New York Times Hurricane Florence is
also president Trump's fault and I'm not
making this up look at the headline on
your screen another hurricane is about
to batter our coasts Trump is complicit
the Washington Post by the way not the
New York Times believe it or not that
headline it's not just clickbait The
Washington Post actually laid out a case
in the editorial for why President Trump
is responsible for bad weather look at
this quote when it comes to extreme
weather mr. Trump is complicit he plays
down humans roles in increasing the
risks and he continues to dismantle
efforts to address those risks not only
is the claim totally absurd it's also
factually wrong not that they really
care the American Enterprise Institute
org AEI org they put out in president
Trump's first year in office the u.s.
reduced co2 emissions more than any
other country in the world
so Trump derangement syndrome is now
reached a new height these people are
just downright sick in their obsession
to hate the president the slogan from
the Washington Post is democracy dies in
darkness
sadly the final nail in the coffin for
democracy journalism if you will is the
kind of blinding anti Trump hatred that
is on display from them and all their
friends in the media almost every day
maybe instead of blaming President Trump
for bad weather and a hurricane
maybe the mainstream media could focus
on the biggest abuse of power scandal in
our history and thanks tonight to the
former FBI lovebirds page and struck we
have even more evidence that your
government was leaking sensitive
information what to destroy Trump from
the get-go first to prevent him from
becoming president then to destroy his
presidency we showed you earlier this
week the newly uncovered text messages
revealing a 20-17
media
link strategy with the FBI coordinating
with the DOJ Sarah Carter also
discovering that struck and Paige were
working on a Russian interference op-ed
in the lead-up to the 2016 election so
there was leaking not only by the FBI
and the DOJ before the election again to
prevent Trump from winning after the
election to destroy a duly elected
president of you the people now Sarah
Carter has obtained even more new text
from struck detailing his cozy
relationship Oh with the New York Times
and one of its reporters Mike Schmidt
April 14 2017 struck texting quote also
apparently The Times is angry with us
about the Washington Post scoop an
earlier discussion that we had about the
Schmidt piece that had so many
inaccuracies too much to detail here but
I told Mike redacted and Andy they need
to understand we were absolutely dealing
in good faith with them struck then
follows up that text with quote the FISA
one coupled with the Guardian piece from
yesterday
the FISA one that's right Peter struck
was helping the New York Times with a
story on the supposedly top secret FISA
Court
this is beyond bad supposedly he's
running the investigation what does it
say about the New York Times what does
it say about the Washington Post all you
need is one anti-trump official to hand
them propaganda misinformation distorted
lies from a known Trump hater at this
point blow it up act as though it's
gospel truth
that's the paper of record where are the
corrections when are they coming
don't hold your breath and we did reach
out to the DOJ The New York Times The
Washington Post and struck and page for
comment we've yet to get a response but
tonight we have brand-new
never-before-seen text messages and now
appears that on top of let's see the
Director of National Intelligence the
FBI and DOJ colluding in all this and
leaking to the press seems like the CIA
they too were involved in the same kind
of illicit leaking and yeah we're
talking about you mister sanctimony John
Brennan Fox news.com just obtained
brand-new text showing that some
officials will quote leaking like mad in
the lead-up to the
TI's Russia Pro why to influence public
opinion take a look at this exchange
this is just after the president got
elected December 15 2016 there they are
again Lisa page texting struck quote oh
remind me to tell you tomorrow about The
Times doing a story about the RNC hacks
struck responding quote and more than
they already did I told you that Quinn
told me that they're pulling all the
stops out on some story you then follow
it up quote I think our sisters have
begun leaking like mad scorned and
worried and political they're kicking
into overdrive
according to reporting from our own
catherine herridge the sisters that
they're referring to that struck
mentioned well that likely is the CIA
that would be John Brennan and Barack
Obama's CIA less than a month after that
exchange that New York Times published a
story about RNC hacks and on the very
same day BuzzFeed published the steel
dossier filled with Russian lies that
Hillary paid for so you have struck
referring to the CIA pulling out all the
stops saying the CIA is scorned and that
their political and their leaking like
mad less than a month later the dossier
becomes public now is this the kind of
politically motivated leaking from our
most trusted government officials is
that acceptable John Brennan I hate to
say that Chuck Schumer's right but if
you go against the intelligence
community they'll get you six ways in
Sunday why because the deep state with
the power that they have intelligence
wise it's like a house of cards we are
watching the whole scheme come tumbling
down revealing a level of corruption in
your government that should make you
sick and concerned and as it turns out
high-ranking deep state officials they
weren't the only people rocked by the
election of Donald Trump look at
breitbart.com they obtained official
video from inside a 2016 company-wide
meeting at the tech giant Google this
was following Trump's win if he thought
the good people of Google weren't biased
and against all things Trump well this
should make you think again let's take a
look you know let's face it most people
here
pretty upset done pretty sad for you
because of the election how was the
first moment I really felt like we were
gonna lose and it was as massive like
kick in the gut that we were gonna lose
and it was really painful it would be
very strong and vocal and you know not
just you know from a press standpoint or
a PR standpoint but actually working
hard behind the scenes to stand up for
what's right I think it's it's worth
being very vigilant and thinking about
all these issues what can we do to lead
to maybe a better quality of governance
decision-making and so forth
is there anything positive you see from
this election result that's that's a
really tough one right now google fair
and balanced just like the New York
Times and The Washington Post and just
like all those deep state actors they
responded to the release of that video
and part quote nothing was said at that
meeting or any other meeting to suggest
that any political bias ever influences
the way we build and operate our
products of course judging from what we
just saw well we could show you an hour
more of exactly the same thing virtually
nobody at least no one in a position of
power at Google wanted Donald Trump to
win
sounds like the CIA FBI DOJ and yeah the
Director of National Intelligence under
Obama according to what we just saw many
actively working against the President
and against the candidate and yet we're
just supposed to believe them that
there's no political bias and they're
biased as an impact any of Google's
products they literally held a funeral
for our country at a company-wide
meeting the day after Donald Trump won
well more on that developing story
throughout the hour but first all right
the countdown continues it's all in your
hands this is where you We the People
have all the power in 55 days the Trump
agenda will move full steam ahead or it
will stop dead in its tracks you get to
decide now some of these races will
literally be decided by just a handful
of votes let's take a look I'll just
list you a bunch of races that are
even Arizona Nevada Tennessee Montana
North Dakota Missouri India and West
Virginia in Florida all of them too
close to call and every one of them like
a knife fight in an alley I mean just
overall in every one of those places
this is a time when your votes gonna
matter do you care would you like the
Trump agenda to continue do you like the
records on the economy we keep talking
about a lot is on the line a lot is at
stake in this midterm election 55 days
away look at this map if you're in one
of these states you literally will
decide whether the Republicans are on
the Senate or Chuck Schumer who says we
can't impeach Trump soon enough we'll
run the Senate you will decide if the
trumpet Genda moves through Congress you
will decide if originalist
constitutionalist judges continue to be
confirmed and look very closely at this
if you live in one of these House
districts well what it really slow you
will decide whether or not the
presidents will face impeachment because
that's what Maxine Waters Nancy Pelosi
Chuck Schumer promised yeah there's a
lot in play here it's that serious
you've heard it from all of them they
want to impeach the President on my
radio show earlier today the former
Speaker of the House Newt Gingrich said
Republicans they need a national
election they need to sign off on a
unified agenda in order to secure
victory now we often talk about the five
things the Democrats are going to do if
they win let's see beats the president
they want their crumbs back they want a
tax increase they want to keep Obamacare
that's worked out so well for so many of
you paying more losing your doctors and
losing your plans of course they want to
eliminate ice they want open borders
well what are the things Republicans
ought to sign on to and promised to you
if they get elected maybe one it could
be to follow through on the Trump agenda
number two secure the border wall and
fund the wall fully maybe they could
support the President's Choice for
constitutionalists originalist on the
court so that you don't have people
literally legislating from the bench or
vote to make the tax cuts permanent why
shouldn't they be permanent it's good
for the economy well
more information about that in a minute
dismantle obamacare replace it with
better plans for example that have more
choices healthcare savings accounts give
you more power health care cooperatives
like our good friend down in Wichita
Kansas doctor Josh umber Atlas MD 50
bucks a month unlimited care and he
negotiates ninety five percent
reductions for any medicines you might
need also how about making America
energy independent we use all our
resources available we got more than the
entire world combined it'd be good for
National Security it keeps us safe it'll
be good for the economy it will create
millions of high-paying career jobs for
Americans and in the process wealth for
Americans so they can buy a nice car a
nice house in a safe neighborhood and
send their kids to whatever they want to
send them to republicans also they've
got to promote just how effective donald
trump has been in the last 19 months
just today get this look at this
we learned that us median income rose to
a record high during the president's
first year in office poverty rate also
fell during the president's first year
millions fewer on food stamps about four
million fewer four million new jobs we
have more manufacturing jobs than we've
seen in 25 years job said obama was
never coming back this country is
literally booming under the president's
leadership and as that happens good news
is bad for the democrats that want their
power back because we had eight years of
failure under their policies and under
obama's policies and on top of that
guess what america would still be even
more prosperous 14 states record low
unemployment record low unemployment for
african-americans Hispanic Americans
Asian Americans 65 year low for women in
the workforce youth unemployment 55 year
low on top of this watch all all the
left they're getting unhinged they are
desperate you got a guy in California
actually trying to stab a GOP
congressional candidate at his campaign
stand police in Washington DC
investigating a threat to commit a mass
shooting at a make America great event
in Trump International Hotel a Wyoming
GOP office was set on fire less than two
days after it opened
Susan Collins she's received over 3,000
coat hangers as she prepares to vote in
the confirmation of Judge Cavanaugh and
her staff has reportedly been receiving
vulgar and threatening phone calls and
promises to fund any opponents she may
have not a good climate for people that
support Trump the rhetoric on the left I
don't blame those people but certainly
it's having an impact on those that have
a tendency to be crazy before something
horrible happens maybe they should stop
telling people on the left to be getting
in people's faces and chasing Pam Bondi
and Sarah Sanders and her kids and
secretary Nielsen out of restaurants